[Musique]
tu souhaites être reporter judiciaire au Japon
pourquoi
tu penses que parce que tu es un étranger les
routes sont différentes
ouais
écoute tu aimes me casser les couilles hein
c'est une grande joie de ma vie
[Musique]
abandonner et rentrer à la maison c'est  pas une
option tu sais ce que je veux dire
tu sais exactement ce dont tu as besoin
[Musique]
et laisse-moi
deviner c'est comme ça que tu recrutes un flic
[Applaudissements]
avec des informations
tout ce que tu fais a des conséquences
[Musique]
il y a toujours un costume
jake  c'est sato il n'est pas aussi
maussade qu'il en a l'air
qu'est-ce que ça fait d'être un yakuza je pourrais
écrire à ce sujet
oui  Musique]
n'écris pas à ce sujet
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
toi